in this video i want to do a bunch of
example problems that show up on
standardized exams and definitely will
help you with our divisibility module
because it's asking you questions like
this all numbers and this is just one of
the examples all numbers divisible by
both 12 and 20 are also divisible
by
and the trick here is to realize that if
a number is divisible by both 12 and 20
it has to be divisible by each of these
guys
prime factors so let's take their prime
factorization the prime factorization of
12 i see 12 is 2 times 6
6 isn't prime yet so 6 is 2 times 3 so
that is prime so any number divisible by
12 needs to be divisible by 2 times 2
times 3.
so its prime factorization needs to have
a 2 times a 2 times a 3 in it any number
that's divisible by 12.
now any number that's divisible by 20
needs to be divisible by let's take its
prime factorization 2 times 10
ten is two times five so any number
divisible by twenty needs to be two
needs to also be divisible by two times
two times five or another way of
thinking about it it needs to have two
twos and a five in its prime
factorization
now if you're divisible by both you have
to have two twos a three and a five two
twos and a three for twelve and then two
twos and a five for twenty and you can
verify this for yourself that this is
divisible by both obviously if you
divide it by 20 if you divide it by 20
if you let me do it this way dividing it
by 20 is the same thing as dividing it
by 2 times 2 times 5. so you're going to
have the twos are going to cancel out
the 5's are going to cancel out it's
going to you're just going to have a 3
left over
and if you were to divide it so it's
clearly divisible by 20 and if you were
to divide it by 12 if you divide it by
12 you divided by 2 times 2 times 3 this
is the same thing as 12. and so these
guys would cancel out and you just have
a 5 left over so it's clearly divisible
by both and this number right here is
60. it's 4 times 3 which is 12 times 5.
it's 60. this right here is actually the
least common multiple of 12 and 20. now
this isn't the only number that's
divisible by both 12 and 20. you could
multiply this number right here by a
whole bunch of other by a whole bunch of
other factors i could call them a
b
and c but this is kind of the smallest
number that's divisible by 12 and 20.
any larger number will also be divisible
by the same things as this smaller
number
now with that said let's answer the
questions as all numbers divisible by
both 12 and 20 are also divisible by
well we don't know what these numbers
are so we can't really we can't really
address it this they might just be ones
or they might not exist because the
number might be 60 it might be 120 who
knows what this number is
so
the only numbers that we know can be
divided into this number well we know 2
can be
we know that 2 is a legitimate answer 2
is obviously divisible into 2 times 2
times 3 times 5.
we know that 2 times 2 is divisible into
it
because we have the 2 times 2 over there
we know that 3 is divisible into it
we know that 2 times 3 is divisible into
it
so that's 6. let me write these this is
4 this is 6. we know that 2 times 2
times 3 is divisible into it i could i
could go through every combination of
these numbers right here we know that 3
we know that 3 times 5 is divisible into
it we know that 2 times 3 times 5 is
divided into it so in general you can
look at these prime factors and any
combination of these prime factors is
divisible into any number that's
divisible by both 12 and 20. so if this
was a multiple choice question and the
choices were seven
and nine
and
why let me end 12 and
let me and eight
you would say well let's see seven is
not one of these prime factors over here
nine
nine is three times three so i need to
have two threes here i only have one
three here so 9 doesn't work 7 doesn't
work 9 doesn't work 12 is 4 times 3 or
another way to think about it 12 is 2
times 2 times 3 well there is a 2 times
2 times 3 in the prime factorization of
this kind of of this least common
multiple of these two numbers so this is
a 12. so 12 would work 8 is 2 times 2
times 2. you would need three twos of
the prime factorization we don't have
three twos so this
doesn't
this doesn't work
let's try another example just so that
we make sure that we understand this
fairly well so let's say we want to know
we want we ask the same question all
numbers all numbers
divisible
by let me think of two interesting
numbers all numbers divisible by
12 and
let's say let's say 9
9 and
let's make it more interesting 9 and
are also
divisible
by are also divisible by
and once again we just do the prime
factorization we essentially think about
the least common multiple of 9 and 24.
you take the prime factorization of 9
it's 3 times 3 and we're done
prime factorization of 24
is
2 times 12
12 is 2 times 6
6 is 2 times 3.
so anything that's divisible by 9 has to
have a
9 in its factorization or if you did its
prime factorization would have to be a 3
times 3 anything divisible by 24 has got
to have a 3 2s in it so it's going to
have a 2 times a 2 times a 2. and it's
got to have at least one 3 here and we
already have at least one 3 from the 9
so we have that so this number right
here is divisible by both by both 9 and
24 and this number right here is
actually 72 this is 8 times 9 which is
72. so if the choices for this question
let's assume that it was multiple choice
let's say the choices here were
16 27
and
and 9.
so 16 if you were to do its prime
factorization is 2 times 2 times 2 times
2 it's 2 to the fourth power so you
would need four twos here we don't have
four twos over here i mean there could
be some other numbers here but we don't
know what they are these are the only
numbers that we can assume are in the
prime factorization of something
divisible by both 9 and 24. so we can
rule out 16. we don't have four 2's here
27 is equal to
three times three times three so you
need three threes in the prime
factorization we don't have three threes
we only have two of them so once again
cancel that out five
five is a prime number there are no
fives here rule that out 11 once again
prime number no 11's here rule that out
9 is equal to 3 times 3 and actually i
just realized that this is a silly
answer because obviously all numbers
divisible by 9 and 24 are also divisible
by 9. so obviously 9 is going to work
but i shouldn't have made that a choice
because that's that's in the problem but
9 would work and what also would work is
if we had a if 8 was one of the choices
because 8 is equal to 2 times 2 times 2
and we have a two times two times two
here four would also work
four would also work that's two times
two six would work since that's two
times three eighteen would work because
that's two times three times three so
anything that's made up of a combination
of these prime factors will be divisible
into something divisible by both 9 and
24. hopefully that doesn't confuse you
too much